[Music]
my plan is to use the digital delay here
like that we have the chromatic
percussion the pitches are set to be
really high it's actually really study
and then if I just play around this time
toggle that also registers I have no
idea
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
okay let's read some comments it's
almost too clear the melody with too
fast yes
less is more yeah I think you're right
did just a toy piano I don't like the
toy now nari I love everything you do
but I think you don't understand the
very thing that makes lo-fi what it is
relaxing yes maybe I need to learn how
to relax honestly really bad oh I mean
it was my first beat this does not sound
like the rainy day in Brooklyn that I
feel when I listen to lo-fi hip-hop
rainy day in Brooklyn okay I think I get
it now
okay I think we should do another one
where you think you know let's let's try
another one
/ - okay let's make something relaxing
[Music]
relaxing so if the first beats that I
created was just an attempt at making a
beat period and combining things that I
wanted to try and just having fun
learning logic and everything this might
be my first mini attempt at an actual
low five beats so let me know what you
think and enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
so I tried to make this beat as relaxed
as possible I took many of your guys's
advice from the comments in terms of
keeping the beat subdued and not
overdoing anything and I used more jazz
chords and I didn't go with the 12 tone
concept this time and yeah I'm still
learning you know baby steps
[Music]
okay Bobby which beat do you like better
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay how about this Bobby
[Music]
[Music]